في عام 1991 ،
مُنح العراق 15 يومًا
للكشف الكامل عن جميع أسلحة الدمار الشامل ،
فقد كان عملًا غير مكتمل منذ
حرب الخليج الأولى وقد
تمكنا من تحقيقه بشكل
جيد ، وأنا مرعوب لأنني كنت جزءًا منه ،
إنه على هذه الحقيقة
[موسيقى] ،
مرحباً
[تصفيق  ]
سارت الأمور بسرعة كبيرة وكان من
المتوقع أن
تسير الحملة عسكريًا بسرعة كبيرة وكان
السؤال الكبير جيدًا ما الذي سيأتي بعد أن
أتذكر أنني اتصلت برئيسي بالجنرال ذو الثلاث نجوم
قائد الفيلق وقلت إن لدي
أخبارًا جيدة وأخبار سيئة  قال ما هو
الخبر السار وقلت الخبر السار
هو أننا نسيطر على الغثيان فقال
مبروك رهيبة ما الأخبار السيئة قلت
إننا نتحكم في نجيف ماذا تريدين
أن نفعل بها
أين هؤلاء الرجال الذين أخبرونا في
الكويت أنك  فقط أوصلنا إلى بغداد
وسنأخذها من هناك ، قال
حسنًا ، اتصل بهم
وقالوا إنهم لا يزالون منظمين ، وهذا يعني أنه
لا توجد سلطات عراقية
هناك لمساعدتنا في تلك
[الموسيقى]
اعتقد الجميع أن جورج  كان بوش بطلاً
بعد حوالي أسبوع من بدء أعمال النهب
وأدرك مواطنو العراق أنه
لا توجد سلطة
ولا سلطة ، وذلك عندما بدأت مشاكلنا حقًا
[الموسيقى] هم
الذين أقنعوا الرئيس
بأنه يتحمل
مسؤوليات سلطة الاحتلال بموجب اتفاقيات جنيف.
وبموجب القانون الدولي يجب أن
يبقى ، ثم يتم
اختيار جيري بريمر ويدخل جيري بريمر
ليكون وحدة التحكم المحترفة وما إلى ذلك
وهكذا دواليك
كنت حاضرًا في اجتماع
قبل غزو العراق مع
الرئيس بوش الثاني  تم اتخاذ القرارات
من قبل الرئيس أولاً: أننا
سننكر
فقط إلى مستوى معين ، وكان القرار الثاني
هو أننا في الواقع
من طائرة عسكرية أسقطنا منشورات
على الجنود وقال جنود
من الجيش العراقي
يعودون إلى ديارهم
وسوف نعيد الاتصال بك
بأحد هؤلاء.  أول الأشياء التي فعلها بريمر عندما
كان في العراق كان بطريقة ما
قلب هذين القرارين
وألغاه ، لقد حظر الجيش بأكمله
وأتذكر أن أحد الكولونيلات
قال لي
هل تعرف ماذا
يعني ذلك أن
شيئًا مثل 50000
عاد جنود الحرس الجمهوري إلى منازلهم بأسلحتهم
وقالوا إنني الآن أعارض الحكومة
تلقائيًا تمامًا مثلما فعل جيري حتى
أنني تلقيت
أمر um قبل أن أغادر
واشنطن ، وقد أعطيتني
وزارة الدفاع وأخبروني
أنها كانت كذلك.  منسقة بالكامل داخل
حكومة الولايات المتحدة ،
حيث
يدلي الناس بتصريحات كاذبة حول هذا
الأمر ، ويقولون إن هذا الأمر قد
أدى إلى انهيار الحكومة العراقية ، وهذا
هراء ، فقد
تم تصميم الأمر للتأثير
فقط على
اثنين في المائة من أعضاء الحزب في الواقع
أحد النتائج.  هل تم
طرد جميع معلمي المدرسة من
مدرسي المدارس الذين تعلمون أن عليهم الانضمام إلى
حفلة الاستحمام من أجل أن يكونوا معلمين
تعلمون أنهم لم يكونوا تهديدًا إلى حد كبير
ولكن لم يتم تعليم الأطفال في
المدرسة لأن المعلمين
تم تجريده من الروعة ، لذلك كان الأمر حقًا
أه
كان حقًا كارثة
جعلته غير مريح بعض الشيء
لأننا في الأساس كنا نقول أن
السياسات التي يتبعها
السيد بريمر هي كارثة وهذا
ما يقودون إليه.
لكننا قدمنا ​​ذلك الإيجاز إلى
الرئيس ونظر الرئيس إلى
بريمر وأتذكر
أنه قال بوضوح كما كان بالأمس ماذا
تقول بريمر وأه
قال السيد بريمر إنني
لا أرى أي طريق للمضي قدمًا سوى على
طول  الأسطر التي نتابعها
الآن وكانت
تلك نهاية الاجتماع
وسارت الأمور من هناك وكان ذلك في
الحقيقة مصدر
الأعداد الكبيرة الأصلية من الأفراد
الذين سيصبحون متمردين أو
متطرفين ، مع
ملاحظة أنه كان لديك البعض الآخر
بالطبع الذين  كانوا حقًا أكثر
من أصبحوا حقيقيين للقاعدة التابعة للقاعدة
في العراق بقيادة الزرقاوي في البداية بالطبع
حتى وفاته في عام 2006.
لكن
هذا كان
هذان القراران كارثيان حقًا
ويمثلان انتكاسات
لم نتمكن من التعافي منها تمامًا.
الجنرالات الأمريكيون الذين
يعتقدون أن هذا كان خطأ لكنهم
لم يتحملوا المسؤولية التي كنت
أتحملها وهي أن أفهمها بشكل صحيح وقد
فهمناها بشكل صحيح
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
الدول المختلفة في المنطقة
لذلك
شجعوا
المتطرفين
على القدوم  من جميع
البلدان المختلفة
لدخول العراق قاموا بتزويدهم
بالمئات
أو الآلاف من السيارات المفخخة
ونجح المتطرفون في
إثارة
التوتر الطائفي بين العراقيين ،
مثل
ما جعل زيادة القوات ناجحة لم يكن
اندفاع القوات بل
هو اندلاع الأفكار.  الطريقة التي غيرنا بها
استراتيجيتنا
وتكتيكاتنا على الأرض
وكان كل ذلك مختلفًا بمقدار 180 درجة عما
كنا نفعله
قبل زيادة القوات ،
فمن الواضح جدًا لنا
أننا بحاجة إلى العودة إلى
الأحياء التي كان علينا تأمينها  لم يكن
بإمكاننا فعل ذلك إلا من خلال
العيش مع الناس
[الموسيقى]
أم
كان خطأً كارثيًا ، وهو ما
نطلق عليه خطأ غير قابل للتحلل البيولوجي ،
فهو لا يزول أبدًا ،
وربما يكون هناك نصف عمر في
نقطة ما ولكن تلك الصور ، تلك الصور لا تزال موجودة
على الإنترنت بسهولة ويسهل العثور عليها
وستظل حافزًا
لأولئك الذين يريدون انتقاد
الولايات المتحدة لتوليد الدعم
للأنشطة المتطرفة وقد
حفزت
العرب السنة على وجه الخصوص
مرة أخرى لمحاربة  الولايات المتحدة
في السنوات التي تلت اكتشاف ذلك
لم يسبق له مثيل في تاريخ أمريكا ،
أذن رئيس الولايات المتحدة
بتعذيب البشر
وهذا ما فعله جورج دبليو بوش
تحت التأثير الكبير لنائب
الرئيس ديك تشيني ومستشاره
ديفيد أدينغتون  لقد انتهكنا القانون المحلي
انتهكنا القانون الدولي بالتأكيد
عندما عذبنا الناس
لم تتحقق أية مساءلة
هم مجرمو حرب إذا كان ذلك يعني أني سأذهب إلى
السجن كمجرم حرب
طالما يذهبون إلى السجن كمجرمي حرب
سأكون سعيدًا.
أتذكر في أغسطس أنه سار عبر
الباب إلى مكاتبنا وقال هل
سمعت أن
جورج الأخير لا يزال يحصل على هذه الصور
على
موقعه على الويب ، قلت الصور قال
نعم صور المختبرات البيولوجية المتنقلة
أنهم لا يزالون هناك و  لقد قلت جيدًا ، من
الواضح أن جورج لا يزال يعتقد أنها
كانت مختبرات بيولوجية متنقلة ،
وقال باول حسنًا ، أعتقد أن هذه هي
المحطة الوحيدة في عرضي التقديمي الذي لا يزال
قائمًا لأن جميع الآخرين قد تم
إزالته على مدار الصيف بعد
أسبوع بعد عودته وهو  يقول
جورج اتصل بي للتو ، لقد
انهارت ساقي الأخيرة ،
ولم تكن هناك مختبرات بيولوجية ،
وأنا جالس هناك أفكر
جيدًا أنك تعرفك ،
وكلاهما ساذج تمامًا لأن الجحيم هذه هي
المشكلة الحقيقية التي نحن ساذجون مثل
الجحيم.
اتبعت
أنشطة طائفية فظيعة أدت
مرة أخرى إلى
نفور العرب السنة مرة أخرى
وجعلتهم يشعرون بأنهم محرومون من ممتلكاتهم وأعطتهم مرة
أخرى حافزًا في
فشل العراق الجديد بدلاً من
نجاحه وبالطبع كان ذلك هو الذي
سمح
للقاعدة في العراق الآن الإسلامية.  الدولة
تعيد بناء نفسها
لتتوغل في سوريا لتكتسب
قوة قتالية إضافية ثم تعود إلى
العراق وتسبب مشاكل كبيرة في
إقامة خلافة كان لها الموصل
مقراً لها في الشمال أه
وبالطبع الرقة حيث مقرها في
سوريا
أجنبي.
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أنه
ربما يكون السؤال الأكبر بينهم جميعًا
لماذا
قرروا الذهاب إلى العراق ،
وأعتقد أنه لا يزال هو
المجهول الكبير
لماذا
بالكاد يستطيع صدام فعل أي شيء
لم يكن يمثل تهديدًا لأي شخص
في ذلك الوقت
لذلك
أنا  لا أعرف أي شخص يمكنه إعطائك
إجابة مقنعة على هذا السؤال ،
وما زال بعضهم يعتقد أن هناك
أسلحة ،
عفواً ،
هذا جنوني ،
عفواً
[موسيقى] [
تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لك